all right bye-bye hello everybody
i hope you're having a great day uh
so first off the
super bet is over right so how did you
guys like that
i really uh wait there's been so many
tournaments recently
but oh no that was my youtube
but now uh i haven't really seen like
magnus nepo that i've been
looking forward to so i started to look
into my own old databases and see if i
could find
a cool magnus snap and cross a nipple
and i found some from when they were
like
babies like under 12 under 14 and
i kind of want to talk about them but at
the same time i was hoping to show
something more recent and there's so
so so many uh draws
so i finally found one that was not a
draw
and i really like this one this one was
actually a very pleasant one
of not for magnus but this was
a i believe in london classic and
i thought it was a cool one because um
we've already seen few games from london
classic
earlier from actually magnus i believe
uh maybe last month yeah we've been
having a magnus
uh magnus search recently
but yeah so if you
didn't get a chance to well bet
on if magnus and nepo can play together
and nepo can win well here's your bets
uh unfortunately i kind of give it up
but we are gonna look at this game
from nepo's side i'm usually a magnus
fan
but this game was too pretty i can i
can't just ignore how
kind of cool this game was so uh
yes apology for the audio and the delay
um i'm still on university campus and
they have been doing constructions which
means sometimes the light goes off
sometimes the water goes up sometimes
the wi-fi
goes off it's more like a russian
roulette at this point
as i've never had all three of them go
off at the same time
but yeah a lot of fun they have promised
that they're going to be done with it
this week at least with my part
at least there are no more fire alarms
so that's another fun part for me
because i've been dealing with morning
fire alarms too at like 8 am which is
actually a good alarm clock
alarm system if they could just be like
for five minutes to make sure i'm awake
and then go away that would be perfect
but i don't think i can request that all
right
so let's just get going with this game
um
and for those of you who are not very
familiar
here uh we do go to leeches after i mean
we are only just right now
but we do go to uh leeches and
twitch after this hour and we'll analyze
your game so if during this
uh hour you kind of want to hear
oh lovely you want to hear me talk and
you want to play under there
from leeches or chess.com or wherever
feel free to have the link saved in the
leaches format and send it to us
when we go to the twitch so
um let's get going
yeah i'm trying to see if was there any
fun backstory to this one
not too much knowledge actually this was
london classic
uh 2017 and i believe this was
the eighth round so not the final round
but
still we all know how those tournaments
can be super duper stressful
i actually think for london classic 2017
i was already here because that was that
would be in december right
i'm pretty sure that would be in
december so i was already here so i
think that's the one that tanya was
around but i had finals
yeah i'm a big fan of tanya too all
right
so uh yeah we have this fun stuff going
on
um i i okay
to be completely honest i don't know how
to feel about a move such as c3
i mean i understand that d4 is about to
come up
and potentially hopefully e4 at some
point
might pop up but i i don't really know
like
if this is more like a blitz move rather
than
a like a real um repertoire
real move right oh well thank you thank
you uh
for the comment in the chat saying that
the resi opening is the most successful
opening for white
that could be true actually uh i'm not
so sure about high level
like 227 plus 2650 plus but
yeah retti is very tricky
so this is kind of like uh magnus is
white and he's like i'm kind of like
inviting you to like a slob with
opposite colored moves
it's like it's it's like a weird one
it's kind of tricky
if you don't really know slov as black
but
black is the very experienced players
so he kind of knows right that's like he
can't really
rely on the fact that oh maybe he
doesn't know
so uh however back
in 2017 from what we looked
um it's like a cool thing that's
at least from 2007 2017 during the 10
years
nepal hadn't really played slov
in like rated games so it kind of made
sense that magnus went for this
but again it's it's a it could be a
bluff like you know
how in poker you're like calling it i
actually don't play poker maybe i should
be using that as a reference
yeah and you're like you want to be a
tempo up sure let's see how this
love will go knight f6 is another
idea that is very very possible and
magnus had played against
i believe jeffrey in the same year
and the game went along to uh
get to like very normal positions and
uh i think magnus won that game
i'm pretty sure he did it was an isle of
man this
this game uh yeah against jeffrey and
magnus was white
so magnus had played this type of weird
openings
uh opening starter
uh earlier i apologize for the mic i
am not sure how to improve it it's a
decent quality mic could be actually
could be better so i'm
not gonna say that's like a full mic but
um
yeah i don't know exactly
what to do at the moment but uh good
news is that
shortly after i believe uh friday
actually i'm gonna be streaming from the
club
so there will definitely be better high
quality lower temperature for me
but hey what to do all right so no
no knight f6 in this game nepo just went
ahead
for um the real deal
and now i kind of want to get you guys a
little warmed up
should we take it
do you want to exchange this love style
[Music]
or if you don't want to take it
yeah uh that could also be my laptop
overheating
i'm gonna put the electronics away from
the
microphone too but yeah it's like you
win some you lose some if i stay here
the problem the microphone problem is a
hit or miss
but if i go to the club there is no cat
so
yeah we kind of do have to take
well let me rephrase it's not that we
have to take we can easily get the
knight out
we can just play e6 but taking is kind
of
um again calling white bluff so we're
getting to exchanges love
and now we just simply develop get the
knights out
and this here is an again another move
that was so
weird for me and i can't really explain
it's any
any better than just saying it was weird
uh so
here it is white's white just device
normally developing right
and neuropal structure normal setting
normal everything
but what should black do normally i
would say maybe get the bishop out maybe
if there's going to be like a knight b5
maybe play a6 to stop that those are the
normal moves
can you think of a little weird
oh thank you thank you chad that's very
sweet of you i'm glad that's there more
uh free time over the summer
yep bishop i i like bishop of five so
i'm not saying no to bishop f5 but
bishop file is not the move that was
played
whoops manish oh yeah dude have you seen
this game i mean i'm sure most of us
have seen this game because
there was commentary i again i'm pretty
sure the club was doing commentary
so most of us have seen this game
but it's highly likely we don't remember
it
that was a bad choice too much bubble
uh i have a thing for bubbly waters and
then every time i drink them i
i'm like ah never again it really
tickles and then again i do it within
the next five minutes so
yeah i like this knight h5 well actually
i kind of like bishop f5 i think that's
more my style
or a6 kind of preventative and then i'm
gonna see how things go
but well i'm not challenging the world
champion
anytime soon so nepo is the one who's
challenging the world champion and he
went for knight h5
yeah so you gotta move this bishop and
now
this again i'm gonna ask you guys do you
think we should just bring this back
or should we just develop wrong piece or
should we just develop
what do you think about knight f6 do you
think knight f6 is cool
weird would you do it in the real game
okay i would do the real game because
against magnus the repetition
earlier repetition is not necessarily
the worst thing so
i would do it depending on the opponents
but do you think knight f6 is the move
that the position
needs
ah i kind of actually like yeah so
that's the thing
i would want to develop i would want to
get the bishop out the
the thing to consider about bishop five
though is e4
that could get a little nasty because if
you just take it now d5
if you just take that then takes over
here and this is actually
a clear advantage for white
so that's kind of what to be worried
about bishop f5 is the
the ideas with e4 and even if you take
it to the bishop
still take take and simply knight gets
to g5 or even e5 that would work too
and black is having a lot of trouble
developing black is having trouble uh
you know getting his pieces out so um
it's a lot of
little issues like that so if you want
to not play
the if you want to develop but not play
knight f6 then you should go for
e6 to make sure that you are still
holding your center
and yeah it's very important because
like this position bishop 5 looks kind
of safe
right air conditioner
but now e4 is going to be quite
problematic
because well what are you going to do
after e4 you can't just not take it and
you can't just take it either way you're
in a pickle
and this is also presents a lot of new
opportunities for
white alright
so i'm glad we covered bishop f5 so you
gotta either go for e6
uh blind the bishop or get your knights
back
what about bishop g4 um
you're not really threatening anything
what if i just go knight e5
if you take it i'll just take that and
[Music]
i'll like i could just poke your bishop
away and then e4s later on would come
with tempo
uh these ideas with g6 look
i mean i think it's doable but i
wouldn't exactly bring the knights
i would simply just get the bishop out
and go for the pressure over here
and maybe bring my knight back to f6 if
needed or if i could
go to f4 i would and then jump back to
e6 i think g6 is
interesting yeah g6 i i put it on the
interesting pile better than bishop f5
definitely and better than bishop g4 but
e6
is more straightforward and then knight
f6 is another valid candidate because
if you just come back okay i could
repeat or i could just ignore the
repetition
and now do something like bishop f5 or h
or a6 or one of these moves that's
more like normal i would i can easily do
those
so um not my tips not
if you don't want to play knight f6 e6
or g6 are your best
bets but after knight f6 trying to go
for
knight e4 maybe it's at least stopping
e4 that's a big part of it
is good and so in this game magnus
simply went for e3
normal stuff
and i kind of feel like this bishops
being blocked
are not exactly pleasant
but you kind of got to do it
uh your bishop is already a little out
so you could do rook c1 ideas but
if we were to play e6 then i'm not sure
what to do with the bishop
but if we were to play knight f5 white
does have a very interesting
what do you think is the best one for
white if we played the special f5
actually
so any suggestions on what whites should
do
white can't exactly do bishop d3 that's
the plus of it
but white does have another pretty cool
idea
any suggestions from the chat
if someone is watching these later and
you want to leave it in the comments too
i uh not every time but
it would be cool like i'm going to try
my best to check the comments as well
queen victory interesting but something
as simple as knight e5
i might want to do stuff in the g file
push pawns there
if you take it then this knight is just
too weird because
you just came up there went there you
come back and then you gotta move it
again
and this could fall and this is too much
too many night moves not worth it
and if you don't take it then what are
you gonna do you have to deal with the
possibilities of bishop b5
or even g4s in the close futures a lot
of issues to deal with
so not exactly worth it
all right let's go back so after
e3 uh e6 was played normal stuff
well white's got the bishop with a good
good place oh
good place was actually a good tv show
if you're gonna try to binge something
the good place was good
i recommend it all right so what now
to be fair if something like bishop b5
was played we could simply do the bishop
d7
and then just get bishop d6 and it's too
it's fine there's not much happening
here you're gonna castle and start doing
stuff in the queen side
it's both board parties have decent
chance
but what if bishop d trina what do we do
and yes white might want to play e4
so should we care about it at the moment
or when it's played we're just going to
take it
we already have puns and some control
over the center so we don't have to be
too worried about it
so do i have to move what should we do
probably get this bishop out so
what do you think oh i gotta wait yeah
what's up
well why can't we just play bishop d6
now who's stopping us
yeah i feel like bishop d6 is a very
logical move to just
have have because a6
as uh like it starts to control the b5
score so i understand that part of it
but he can just castle and immediately
play e4 or knight e5 right now
so there is a few things that are
unpleasant
so if bishop d6 if you were to do knight
b5
i could simply just come bishop b8 and
castle and shortly after
just start kicking your knight and i'm
the one who wants to play e5s now
because you don't have e4 anymore that's
actually better for black
yeah this is definitely more pleasant
for black
if you play knights b5 i'm still gonna
keep the control of this
the diagonal yeah
oh thank you patrick all right so
uh in the game magnus just went for e4
how do we feel about this scared happy
ouchy
positive feelings negative feelings what
do we have
anybody
yeah i think e4 is you kind of gotta do
it
because if you don't play e4 you're
gonna probably castle or play rook c1
or and then you have to uh consider the
issues that black could actually play
the
e5 so you kind of have to be prepared
for that
yeah so e4 was played and then we got to
take it because if we don't take it e5
is coming up we don't want to deal with
that
and we can't exactly play e5 ourselves
because we uh
he takes over here with knight also
yeah and this is not very pretty
all right so um e4
just take it take and then what do we do
we don't do we want to take that too or
do we want to just move the bishop
ah good one edo
so manage that is true white does end up
with the isolated pawn
but that's not the end of the world uh
depending on the position isolated pawns
could actually be quite beneficial
so if for example one side has isolated
pawns
that's something that it's beneficial in
the middle game
mostly it's beneficial in the middle
game because it gets them the
more like center uh it gets them like
the the files that are between us and
like
because the pawn is usually going to be
in the center
the um the diagonals behind it's like
the
right snout like the h1 sorry h5 v1
diagonal is another
one that's uh white actually owns
basically
so uh it's not bad but if we end up if
we go to the end game
then this could become a target
yeah i like it let's just get the bishop
out of the way
and if we took knight e4 that's okay
but you can't exactly castle right now
because
this your king is too lake it and if you
don't remember what lake it is
i think last week or the week before
that
we talked about the concept of lakehead
that i created the king is naked
and lonely so can't have a
lake it king yeah
it was funnier last time i said it but
yeah so we don't necessarily want this
kink to be around you
all lonely oh that was a loud air
conditioner oh my god
and so yeah i think that's the best
thing that's right now black
uh has to deal with this little issues
of the king so has to bring up some
coverage
has to bring up some um oh he has to
wear a mask
yeah exactly
so uh we don't exactly want to have to
deal with that so
uh 97 is the best way to go if you end
up in this position
and now you can castle and now black
has to deal with well let me ask you
bishop h7 good or bad what do you think
about this
is it a good idea for white to take on
the pawn on h7
oh my teapot
i have this little cute i actually i had
this little cute teapot
and i washed it and i had still have no
idea how
but it broke so i amazon another one
and i'm very careful not to break this
one because
i like my teapots
but this one is too big this is like
twice the size of the last one i had
so what do we think bishop b7 good or
bad
let me show you bishop 7
take check and now what do you think is
the best move for black
should if to be fair if you just go back
there is going to be
queenish five problems and cut bye-bye
peter it wasn't that expensive i think
it was i believe
ten dollars eleven it wasn't that
horrible
yeah exactly king g6 and no more queen
no more funny business and if queen g4
bam f5
and if queen and that kind of stops at
all black has an extra piece
and you gotta move the queen and my king
can simply just try to
run away that way so
bishop h7 not a good idea but white
can't try to prepare for it but it can
try to go like queen c2
and then knight to e5 and then make it a
little harder for black to complete the
development
like if you move the then yeah you know
you can't move the bishop you can't
exactly take over here because that's
your good bishop
this is like there's like it's too just
meh
like all like pushed together i i we
don't really want that
so it for creates that's another way to
deal with it
oh fruit fly yeah
and something like knight e5 is also
another way to consider
and the white just feels more
comfortable so that's why
we don't exactly want to take it over
here so if we don't take it
we're probably going to play this bishop
e7 save the bishop
castle castle queen c2 and
finally another question for you guys do
should we do h6 or g6
what do you think which one
which one do you think is well i was
gonna say safer
but uh which one do you feel more
comfortable with as black
yeah me too i feel more comfortable with
h6 as well because if we were to play
g6 oh somebody subscribed somewhere
that's kind of fun ah thank you for the
subscriptions that i'm seeing on
i believe youtube thank you oh another
one
lovely so yeah if you play this g6 the
issue
is well there's a bunch of issues but
one of the easter one of the bigger
issues is just
work d1 how do you want to develop let's
say you just
play normal moves play normal moves but
this is too
um uncomfortable oh that's a big
squirrel on my
patio yeah
this is this is just uncomfortable you
never know
how to deal with this um
potential bishop h6 potential knight fab
there's just too much potential for
opponents
yeah exactly if i don't have to i don't
want to play this
so h6 is the way to go rook d1
bishop d7 now can someone tell me what
is wrong with knight d4
can we play this knight d4 do you feel
comfortable with this
and while you do that i'll tell you a
tiny portion of what i'm watching right
now
there was a really cute squirrel i don't
still know the difference between
squirrel and chipmunk i've been living
here for four years i still don't know
it
but um there is this really cute
squirrel who
just went right behind the window where
peachy's napping and just looked at pj
and
she's completely out of it so
[Music]
peachy is uh sunbathing slash napping
catnapping
yeah it's way too hot here so
his majesty is just like i'm out
oh yeah she didn't even wake up to trip
at the squirrel
all right what's what draws wrong with
knight d4 well nobody told me what's
wrong with knight d4
all right so the issue with knight d4 is
that white can just take it
and this here it's not exactly
like the end of the world you're not
gonna lose material but you're gonna
lose a lot of tempo like bishop can just
move away
and then this can happen and this is
very uncomfortable
i mean white is still not winning white
has advantage
and white has initiative and white has
diagonal and white has like this
stuff on the king but it's not the end
of the world like if you wanted to eat
that pawn and play a very defensive very
kind of game you can definitely do that
but i would not
advise that we care too much about peace
activity to just
lose it like that so just bishop d7 you
want to do drug c8
in the game magnus just play the chill
move rook c8
and he just played knight c3
now what do you think about this knight
c3 knight c3 definitely a good idea but
what do you think should happen
what do you think black should do now
oh something's under me
since um what was it like two weeks ago
i had a squirrel trapped in my
broom i've been very um i don't want to
say scared but
yeah it's kind of terrified that like
i'm gonna step on a squirrel there's
gonna be like
family of squirrels just falling through
the ceiling
so much fun living in the nature
all right any suggestions
it doesn't look that scary honestly but
yeah so knight c3 is actually a very
well calculated
very well presented
i think so too that's a like you want to
cover up the queen and at the same time
you want to keep
your diagonal open so i like that
all right so uh after knight c3 black
just played
a6 i mean honestly black could have
considered knight d5 or knight
a5 or like bishop d6 and i bring like
the knight around
and bring this bishop this one is one of
my most favorite with bishop d6
but i think the idea of a6 is to play
bishop dc so i'm not nitpicking on it
and so magnus played a very very cool
move
so why to move what do you think white
should do i'll give you guys a minute
because this move is not too hard but
it's a beautiful move so it would be
good if
um you guys could you know take a minute
and just see how things are
squirrels are cheeky i do not know what
that means
i still i mean i'm still i'm telling you
i keep looking at the difference between
chipmunks and squirrel
i still don't know it
uh no i'm just i clicked on the king to
let you guys
make sure you guys um remember to look
for white move
it's not a it's not kingish one no no no
no no
um i think rookie one is normal
but but it's like think of a magnus move
right now is your queen doing anything
here uh-uh no
it's not a king move nope is your queen
doing anything here is there a piece
that you could improve
if you wanted to improve bishop f4 is
possible or q1
is possible those are fine moves
knight t5 is also cons worth considering
but my biggest problem is knight d4
and your queen is kind of just on the
way
so not nice e5 is your queen doing
anything useful here because if not we
gotta we gotta relocate it
what do you think also i'm a very big
fan of this cup i've had it for a while
and i keep drinking it and i still like
it
i think i like the blue color
yeah exactly queen c1
yeah exactly exactly quincy one you
might want to start considering
doing stuff on h6 yeah
and you can start thinking about knight
t5 because knight d4 is no longer
with tempo so
magnus finds a way to kind of make the
most of this coin
and i agree he does what else
so um that's kind of one of the things
to be cautious
when you play this kind of
h6 is something to be very cautious of
that potential takes
i think yeah i was thinking i in the us
champs which was like six oh my god it
was like
nine months ago i could have had a full
baby ah that's
sorry i've been um studying too much uh
but no like us chances like what's eight
months nine months ago
and um i i think in the second
second round or third round third round
yeah
i had a game like this i was playing
italian
and like my opponent had this setup that
i sacrificed on
and i thought i had a good position but
i was wrong and i was
i got into some real mess and i managed
to escape it and i got advantage and of
course i blew it so
they gave it a draw in a good
old-fashioned manner she wins she even
she was she even she wins she wins and
then
well draw yeah so this is a target take
that target seriously and if you
haven't watched um game analysis that i
did that i played
in us championship feel free to check
those out they were both on twitch and
youtube i think on youtube i did my most
favorite ones
all right yeah so h6
this is a clear target so how do you
think magnus should do it
he can't exactly defend this right now
so best he could do is
move the rook around and try to defend
it from under so
oh carpenter i agree yeah he does he
karpov is a big
yeah i can think of different games of
powerpuffs that he just
maneuvered around on his first rank
but i like to circuit it's rookie it
ideally i would want the strike to be
in a more active position like either
you know out here
doubled up or like a d file but at the
moment this should do
and if i get the chance to play e5 even
better
so uh opponents played rook f1 and
magnus played rook f1 2 bishop f8 and
finally white plays bishop before so
this game so far
magnus has better development better
piece coordination
better piece activity better structure
the only thing is like potential for
[Music]
isolated pawn targets for the future his
eyesight upon being targeted the future
there you go that's the right
grammar on that sentence so what do you
think black should do now
the rook over here could become
interesting but how
back to move what do you think we should
do um
i'm not the i'm not a fan of light h5
slide h5 is
just kind of the bishop is already
defended with the queen so i'm not
exactly
attacking anything that's serious
b5 there we go yeah b5 and you want to
push b4
if we move b4 take take and magnus point
knight e5 so
now should we eat this bishop
and another question if we could if
taking this bishop is good
well why did the magnus just move this
bishop away the last one
right you could have easily done that
yes it is good to take it over here
and yes it would have been interesting
if you just moved it away
if you just move it away then i'm gonna
come after this bishop
and this bishop is more important than
this bishop
in this attack which i know it's kind of
weird to say but the dark squared bishop
is
currently more important than the light
squared bishop
because this is kind of coordinate
making this coordination
with the queen yeah
so we don't exactly so black is more
comfortable in this position
and for those of you who are not very
comfortable with how to play against
isolated pawn you block it you put a
knight in front of it
and you say yay then you go drink some
tea
but yeah basically isolated pawns are
there to be blocked if you can
block it you can start attacking it you
can
target there are like three squirrels in
my backyard staring at my cat
my cat is not food for squirrels this is
so weird why are they looking at him
i'm a little scared i want to wake him
up and make sure nobody's
making dinner plans for my cat alright
yeah
bishop e1 is fine but knight e5 is much
more
magnus yep because if it was me
the first thing i would want to do is
just run away with the bishop i want to
keep my bishop i don't necessarily want
to
um give dinner
to my opponent's knight yeah
so uh knight t5 was played and after
knight e5
take take and now what do you think
black should do
there are few ideas one of them is
bishop
oh oh my god one of them is this with
bishop b5
one of them could be just to ignore that
sign and let the bishop stay
i kind of think we should be five is
worth considering but it's not the move
that nipple played
what do you think nepal played
butcher sauces upon kind of not exactly
so
if you put in this bishop b5 take take
take
you get to win the d5 square and that's
very important because this is
completely no danger for black the
knight on d5 is basically holding
everything together
this is super super night and you're
gonna get to get your bishop out of here
next move
so this extra pawn is just a target it's
not exactly an advantage
at this moment so bishop b5 is
interesting but it kind of
also simplifies the position too much oh
i have a cool question about
uh how do i know which bishop is more
interest more valuable well
um that's a good question especially
because the light-skirt bishop
right behind the pond seems to have more
room right
but um in this specific position
this bishop is more important because
it's participating in
attack and it's also participating in uh
blocking this other diagonal for
opponent's bishop so because your bishop
is making my bishop more miserable
that's kind of the that's kind of the
the way to think about it because well
one of the other things that we usually
talk about
in our lessons is how to make opponents
more uncomfortable
so um that's kind of the basis of the
psychology that i like oh
that's actually a good question yeah um
so we are trying to
not only advance our position but make
opponents position
more uncomfortable as as we do improve
our position too
and which bishop makes opponents
position more uncomfortable
well this bishop right now this bishop
this bishop the f4 bishop makes it more
uncomfortable
because
the other little issue is that
in the other line if you just save this
bishop you give your opponent enough
chance to come and start poking your
bishop
and win the d5 square when in this line
opponent has to waste another move and
then start to think okay should i play
bishop b5 now
it kind of buys you more time as white
to have to deal with the
upcoming blockade of the pawn
um mimi i don't understand your question
i thought it was onions but i guess
apples work too
alright so i hope that makes sense
sometimes it's a little
um harder to explain what these big guys
do
that's why we have a super commentary
team to sit there and
talk about the games live for like uh
six hours or so yeah
all right so uh in the game knight e5
take take and um
nepo just played this a5
i think a5 is another way to just try to
do stuff in the queen side because we
thought about bishop b5 and bishop if i
was fine
but it kind of simplifies the position
too bad
all right so a5 and carlson just went to
queen f3
i love this movie i think it's such a
cool move you are
again not directly threatening anything
but you're definitely stopping this
knight d5s you're stopping any like
bishop c6
ideas nowhere bishop bfob you're just
putting pressure on the opponent again
so that's like one way to think about it
it's like
which way puts more pressure on the
opponent and this queen f3 puts a lot of
pressure on the opponent
this is a useless bishop you can't
exactly move this bishop with happiness
and yeah actually while i said that uh
opponents here nepal played bishop b4
bishop b4 is a mistake can you tell me
why
and while when you tell me why you can
tell me
what happens what do you think is the
best move instead of bishop before so i
have two questions for you
why is bishop before bad so please tell
me a line so how can white use this
bishop bad bishop before
and what do you think should have
happened instead of bishop before
so what do you think should have
happened instead of this bishop b4
yeah bishop h6 is the first thing that
comes to mind but let's say bishop
6 just pawn takes then what
not exactly so bishop h6 is the way to
go
but if you were to take it the
problem is not taking here
the problem is something else the
problem is how this queen and this
knight are working together on the f7
square
how can we use that
no the queen is not overloaded because
if you take it just takes back with the
knights
so that's not the problem the problem
is knight to e4 going after this knight
if you move it then finish
queen takes over here knight g6 and bye
bye that's checkmate
so you can't exactly do that either so
yeah that's a very cool critical
position of it
and if you just bring the bishop back i
can definitely
either play just bring the rook up and
want to give you checks or or i can just
go d5
all in yeah
good great i'm saying that the chat is
also warming up to this attack idea
so after take the best way to continue
would be to take here
take back and then take this check and
king would move away
if king f8 this actually is a bad idea
what do you think white can do after
king f8
exactly exactly so that's why we start
with bishop c3
but king f8 is wrong can you tell me
what's the best move that
black white can do after king f8
we need to bring in more pieces how
nah queen is four is not exactly the
right way
we gotta bring in other stuff ooh peachy
saw the squirrel
and he is awake if you're lucky
okay he's getting closer she's right
here now
but he's too um fascinated with the
squirrel so i don't know if you're gonna
get a cat
yeah rook d3 exactly
if you try to run boom if you try to
run just d5 the center is too
uh mobile and if you try to just
you know i don't know develop it or take
over squares
again and now i can again
use my queen and bring the rook behind
it and
this is going to be the end d5 also
coming up don't forget about d5
so king if it's not what about king h7
now what do you think white's gonna do
rook dieter is much more convenient than
rook e3 your rook on e5 is
doing something your default is not
exactly
um if knight d5
we can take a quick look at it sure so
we talked about king effect and there's
a question what's the difference between
e3 and rick d3 uh rook e3
oh i was thinking maybe this
knight can do something but apparently
bishop maybe bishop c6
or even bishop like a4 to gain more
tempo
and try and open up some routes for the
king
that would be interesting
uh yeah i wasn't considering a bishop a4
initially but
yeah that could be an interesting
difference because now people are like
bishop b5 you're just kind of pushing me
but if i'm playing playing rookie three
and then you bring your bishop up
real quick three is not exactly you're
not really pushing me anymore
because i'm just kind of giving you
a bunch of pieces and
black has enough pieces to have a tiny
advantage in this line
so we don't want to do that we don't
want to give up free stuff we want to
sacrifice stuff we want we don't want to
just give it up for
for no reason all right so king h7
now what should we do
yeah so we already sacrificed this
bishop
how can we make better use of it as
whites oh yeah that's white
yep take this free stuff and we can
bring the queen join the check and
keep the knight safe next we're going to
bring the rooks
or first throw in the check and
we don't want to exchange i kind of like
this knight g6 idea
i think with g5
yeah and if you try to chase me fine and
i'll eventually eat over here
and this is a much more
convenient position for white white just
has a
load of pawns yeah this is too
comfortable for a white
all right yeah this is a long line again
nobody's gonna be able to
see every single move it was like what
10
10 move here uh yeah this was like 12
moves
so you're not going to be able to see
exactly what's going to happen you can
have an
idea about it but as i believe as long
as you see
this line down until knight f3 and you
see this check it's good enough you can
go for it
because if you try to um
like even if if you see up until this
position
you know that you at least have two
pawns for the bishop that you gave up
you have
mobile center and you can bring up your
rook and you still have that
knight and queen that are super active
so you don't have to worry about how to
continue the attack as long as you know
that the attack exists and thank you for
subscriptions
so there we go uh you have that oh that
was a
long line and finally bishop b4 is a
mistake
that magnus did not use he didn't just
take on bishop h6 he should have done
bishop h6
he didn't so what does this teach us you
can mess up
it's okay to mess up a little bit you
don't not necessarily go blunder around
but it's fine to mess up
in one mess up two mess up doesn't
necessarily mean that
you're definitely going to lose yes if
magnus saw bishop h6 and if mike has
decided to play research 6 he would have
had a more
pleasant position but even the world
champion can
mess up and not exactly use the event
that the opportunities that he was given
so
you don't have to play perfect games
just have to play in knowing games
you have to make sure to annoy your
opponents and i don't mean kick him
under the table
even in online games you can't even do
that and online games i've seen that
people just chat and i don't get that i
always disable the chat
i mean i want to hear from you the best
i can give you is a
hello hello good luck good luck that's
it i don't want to sit there and chat oh
you should have done that you should
have done this no i'm there for the
blood
okay maybe not blood but the breaking
points
and the wind maybe i should stop talking
if my opponents start going missing oh
boy
all right
all right so uh instead of bishop b4 the
best move that white uh black should
have done was
not bishop before it was queen e7 and
you should like black shirt on this like
eat slowly slowly
if you try to take it i'll take it to
the light sorry
if you try to be cute about it i'll just
move this knight away
and take i'll just take back if it is
it's a balanced position you don't have
to worry too much about it
so yeah um
queen e7 just it's a weird move i agree
but even if you don't want to play queen
e7 just a4 you got to do something
bishop b4 is not the answer this bishop
is here defending everything
so magnus didn't take under sticks he
just played ricky three i think
i mean obviously he saw bishop h6 i
don't know why he didn't play it
honestly
and i don't think i can just email him
and ask
but he didn't take it which is fine he's
not exactly the end of the world
butcher 6 would grant him easier game
and
advantage but it wasn't like a winning
move
it was advantageous yeah we're trying to
go for the g
file so uh
in the game take tank
and they kind of that was like a
positional transformation right so we
changed the pawn structure and it does
favor white
a little bit so because there are a
bunch of threads in the king side
and the c4d5 ideas of the pawns so
black to move how do you think we can
activate our pieces we need to activate
these pieces
we need these pieces to be activated
what do you think we should do
while you think what black should do i'm
gonna tell you a tiny
story um
so in the interviews that
the interviewer were having with the
players
i don't remember who was there but i
think maurice
was in london 2017 for this so
he might have been the one who
interviewed i am not sure but
well anyways in some of the in an after
game interview
magnus said that um
he failed to predict a single one of
nepal's moves
which is kind of weird because minus is
usually good at predicting moves on like
reading the opponent but in this case he
was not
in this game so i i'm not entirely sure
if he was having a bad day or whatever
ah okay
that actually does explain if it was if
it had a little cold
that could explain it yeah physical uh
physical
uh illness even a little one or mental
illness those can
just drain you i like i i've experienced
it myself but just
whoa yeah so 95 could be interesting but
the
issue is exactly take and this is not
exactly pleasant so keep the knight
where it is
what about the bishop can we do anything
with this guy
could she oh i have a cat under the
table who just sneezed
oh
exactly bishop a4 let's go get this
bishop activated the rook moves
and now what do we do to be fair eric c1
would have been better
uh rook c1 you have to be cautious does
queen d4 work
because you can't exactly take it you
know oopsie daisy
so class coin d4 work after rook c1
what do you think
because if queen d4 works that explains
why magnus didn't play rxc1
does it work
while i while waiting for you guys to
answer that question the
big idea after bishop a4 is to try and
play bishop c2 and cover up around here
so uh brook d
or c1 queen d4 it actually does not work
it's not because of bishop h6
well i mean does it work like is it a
good move because if he takes then let's
check might well that's how
that's what i mean by work honestly um
but that's not exactly how it's going to
go but there's six
that does deserve a little attention but
that's not the best one either
how about yeah exactly okay one simple
attacks
keep it keep it classy and if you
um try to take
over here uh bishop h6
and now you have a big issue
so whoops i just hit the microphone
so yeah that's one of the reasons point
d4 does not work
white has definitive advantage so rook
c1
what do you think should happen after
rook c1
what do you think
so yeah um i i kind of like the rook e7
suggestion
maybe move the bishop suggestion but the
best one is
we ultimately the biggest thing we want
to do is knight d5
but we can't do that just yet because of
the f7 pawn
so i'd like to turkey 7 i need to try
and cover it up but rookie 7
it can has its own issues because it
kind of stops
severs the connection that's the right
word it severs the connection so taking
could happen
and then you know you just lose a pawn
and your king is about to
in farsi i would say cad lepage like
gets upside down and then
you know you make the king upside down
you shake it for the coins
i don't know if that's a good
representation of what i have in mind
but yeah basically
so the king is about to go down in the
gutter i think that's the american expo
oh my god i'm
feeling way too many english language
like
stuff i've been doing uh passages all
day and i've been reading
two different um
too much art stuff yeah not fun i'm not
the biggest fan of arts
reading about art and history is fine
literature is okay
but if it's boring if i can't understand
half of the words that are on the
on the english part of it it's not fun
okay so uh yeah instead of bishop berkey
seven just gonna run cafes keep it keep
it
classy yeah oh taking a beating take a
beating yeah that would actually
be what i meant that would be a better
representation of what i've meant
yeah so rook f8 is a good idea too
because well that's actually the best
lighter you stop the
stuff that's going to happen on f7 and
next you just want to do a knight d5
so rook f8 is the best way to go about
it and if you try to you know
still hold hopes for knight d5
c4 and you don't exactly need to
worry too much about this knight because
you can counter attack
take that guy and this is a very normal
opening
this is a very normal position the
central pawns are kind of
uh kind of cancel out this awkward spawn
structure the black has got going
so white has like a tiny advantage but
it's nothing to be super scared of
you still have a decent bishop if you
can activate it you can
consider exchanging the queens that
would be a good idea
um so
bear beer underage beer whoa
that's that's a good username yeah the
issue with queen d4
was not the fact that he could take it
it was that first of all bishop h6
second of all um rook a1
the rookie one is a real issue because
um well how are you going to get away
with this your queen is under attack
you can't move the queen anywhere
without losing the bishop
uh dance bike my mic is good my laptop
is the one that's making the little
funny um noises i think the mic is too
good
picks up all the little noises ha
yeah yep basically that's a big problem
that you just lose the bishop all right
so uh bishop c3 take band
magnus just went for rook a1 we follow
or not we
nipple followed with nice bishop c2 that
was kind of the original idea to
relocate the bishop right
now um i still don't understand why
magnus played h3
but the fact that he had a common cold
might to actually explain that
yeah i don't really understand h3 this
is
a you like you might want to bring your
rooks over here so h3
i i don't i don't get it uh but
now black could actually play knight d5
now knight d5 you gotta be careful
because you have to uh understand the
the worries about bishop h6
but if bishop h6 white uh could
sorry black could not doesn't have to
take it you can just get the queen out
but i'm not very comfortable with this i
don't really want to get myself in a
position
that i have to do so much calculations
about am i going to get mated or not
well can i just avoid the the problem
by not giving my opponent a chance to
try to checkmate me
because i that would be ideal for me i
don't want to i don't want to do this
i i think something like a4 might be a
little bit more chill
just keep it classy just make sure
everything is protected
and the chance yes try to protect f7 and
then on only then do this knight d5
that's what i would go for
and uh nepal played bishop f5
which was not very smart because of this
g4
and now what are you going to do with
your bishop he put this bishop on
h7 which well the bishop seems like it's
kind of covering the king and
has a decent diagonal right but it's not
exactly the truth
because it's not really helping out
and this gave white the chance to want
to play g5
or c4 and magnus didn't play g5
that was kind of the the fun parts
funny part about it because usually when
you're playing the world champion
and you give him one chance he's gonna
just
just make sure you never give him
another chance again
so you don't want to give the world
champion a chance to
get his pieces this activated and this
would be the second mistake that nepal
made
however in this game he was lucky he
didn't really
get punished at all because he won the
game but you didn't get punished for
um this mistake that he made his first
mistake was the bishop b4 idea
and the second one was getting the
bishop back to f5
but yeah um
exactly grade 12 that's another good
point if you were gonna play bishop h7
from the beginning
why would you give white to g4 i
completely agree with that
so g5 now would be the best idea and
then boom knight f7
and uh this would actually leave black
with the real issues why it does have a
i want to say at least um advent
the white has good advantage it might
not it's not winning advantage but
it's like plus one one and a half so
it's it's good
good enough good enough for magnus to
bring more pressure
and doesn't don't won't let you forget
what you just did yeah so g5 would be
the best one but he went for
c4 and now uh
nepo started to actually play a little
bit better he went for knight d7
and this knight c6 again doesn't really
make much sense
so i'm gonna have to put this loss on
magnus's cold and
just say that he had a cold what to do
yeah so c5 is the way to go because c5
you are making sure that your passpond
is actually
passed on and at the same time if take
take
now this f6 on ideas it's okay because
you have this bishop is
kind of protecting the king but you're
like just look at this position white's
position is just completely
just just pushing and just making sure
you can't breathe
i got a cat on the table all right so
um knight c6 again a tiny mistake and
inaccuracy it's not a blunder it's
definitely an accuracy
which ma nepo saw and he just
went for the good move good idea make
sure to keep the queen
uh pinned losing that pawn doesn't
matter
as much because now this is another
target
and now magnus made the wrong move i've
played c5
c5 makes no sense because
oh this is just this is a pin this is
this is a blunder
because if you play this
i will simply just take that right it's
a blender
and that's not a very fun thing for
magnus to deal with
so he took this and again this makes not
not much sense because the best way to
deal with it is like okay i made a
mistake i gave up the pond that i had
it's okay let's just make the most out
of it and just exchange the queens
uh accept that you made a mistake and
just um kind of accept that this is
going to be
unpleasant but most likely uh still good
still decent fighting chances but he
didn't and
he just took took and just gave black
an extra pawn as well and the fun part
was he didn't even take it over here
because
if he took white is
having oh thank you for the subscription
white is having
a very unpleasant position and as upon
down
but it's not the end of the world he's
not lost yet
but the way that white played it with
queen c6 this is a blunder whoops
now what do you think black is gonna do
block to move
what to do and while you guys do that
i'm gonna double check on the chats
see what i missed
what did i miss
ah yeah the little um
yeah it does look like he gave up my
little uh that's not exactly arabic
that's
uh far c uh we have
um we have the
uh we have similar alphabet farsi and
arabic
but this is the translation far c
means june this is not arabic
and june the translation of farsi to
english
i think armenians also do say june or
john
means uh deer yeah like it was supposed
to be like a funny
uh dear magnus this one you kind of
messed up
yeah it's okay all right so queen c6
queen a4 exactly thank you queen a4 and
now you are forking then the bishop and
the queen
and this is a full piece this is
completely lost for white
here white played uh queen a4
and the take back and just played c6 but
this is completely lost
all you have to do is just make sure to
stop
the pawn pushing and just put your
knight to see it and don't even bother
with this
and that's actually how nipple saved
this game nipple was
worse most of the middle game and he
made mistakes too
but magnus was ultimately the one who
didn't use his
nepal's mistakes and he made the final
mistake
so i guess what you can learn from this
the psychology part of it
is what i've always been talking about
peace activity
peace activity peace activity that's a
big thing that you need in chess
besides peace activity and besides good
calculation you also need to be able to
make your opponent miserable you've got
to make your opponent miserable you
can't just play good moves you got to
play annoying moves you got to make them
i was going to say regret they were born
but i thought that that's a little too
mean but you're gonna make them
uncomfortable
to say the least um and
on another note in order to actually win
a great game
and especially win world champion or win
tournaments in order to win
most things in your life not just hard
work you need
luck luck you need it i know i need it
when i
when i win something i know i need it
when i take an exam i know i need it
when i
have a good day luck has a big part so
it's not just
good chess it's even if you're a great
chess player you could make mistakes you
could have a bad day you could have a
common goal like magnus had here
and you could lose it's okay it's not
about winning every single game
so i hope you enjoyed this uh hopefully
i didn't really
tank your inspirations and everything
this was a fun game for me because
i always like it when world champions
make mistakes and they lose because it
gives me
the hope that i can beat them one day
too and
uh yeah so we're gonna take a short
resource i'm gonna say about five to
seven minutes
recess well i guess break and we're
gonna do a switch to twitch so we're
gonna go stream on twitch
i wanna analyze your games so uh please
make sure to have games ready and send
them to me on leachat's format
they just link in the twitch chat so
make sure to have all your games ready
and meet me on twitch in about five
seven minutes i'm just gonna
make some changes on the computer and
refill my tea
all right great uh i'll see you guys
shortly on
our twitch channel